hi there
steve kaufman um i'm going to do a few
videos here um yeah
i don't know how how much patience
people have to watch these things that
seem to
last a long time but i'm lazy i don't
want to write
so i'm going to speak here first of all
i went to the
convention of the american council of
teachers
of foreign languages in san diego uh
i must say i enjoyed it it was a
pleasure
to leave the rainy climate of vancouver
and go down to where the sun shines
i enjoyed san diego i got a real deal on
a hotel which turned out to be right
near the airport so it was about a 45 to
50 minute walk
in and back every day but i didn't mind
that i was
walking along the bay and it was very
pleasant
overall i was impressed with many things
at the
convention i was impressed by the
quality of the teachers that i met
many of them native speakers who spoke
the language that they were teaching
very well whether it was french or
japanese or chinese or spanish or
you know german or whatever
the seminars that i attended varied from
completely useless discussions about
you know research opportunities uh
presented by one professor
in heavily accented english he was
chinese he was talking about
different kinds of research that
demonstrated that
you know amongst other things that
advanced readers
read better than intermediate readers
and all kinds of useless junk
uh that was a downer uh the
there was some discussion about how
people introduced drama in their
classrooms and this kind of thing which
is okay it's not
my thing i don't really go for that i
just prefer
listening and reading
and there were some very interesting
discussions on new technology the ipod
you know it was a real revelation to me
to realize that there have been a
hundred thousand apps
applications apps written for the iphone
ipod touch
as opposed to 600 for blackberry and
60 for samsung or nokia or whatever
so there's this tremendous
uh outpouring of creativity
for this ipod iphone ipod touch
and even if you were to search the app
store looking for i don't know german
flash cards
you find lots like there's just more and
more applications being written for that
that have to do with language learning
there are a number of discussions
where university language teachers were
very frank
in stating that the era of the teacher
as the fount of knowledge and wisdom and
the instructor who's going to show you
how to do it
is already over and that the teacher
is there to direct traffic maybe to help
to uh coach to encourage to learn
because very often the students are much
more with it
in terms of the new technology than the
teacher
as an example i met a delightful teacher
of chinese a chinese lady
who has incorporated ipods and she
creates flash cards with
sound for learning characters for her
class and she
learned a lot about how to do it and how
to
follow up on what her students are doing
uh from her teenage daughters
so i think there's a lot of this going
to happen that the technology is
happening faster and the
the acceptance of the technology is
greater amongst young people
and the teachers are kind of out of it
and they're going to have to learn
there was one uh seminar on the ipod
and and the classroom and 80 people
showed up
but the presenter didn't show up and so
though
then a group of us stayed behind and
those of us who are using the ipod such
as we are at link
we started talking about what we did and
i was absolutely amazed
to hear the number of people who said
that they didn't know
what an ipod was well i am
quite convinced that at the next
conference of the a
c t f l or ftl whatever in boston
uh many many more people will know what
an ipod is
and how to use it i think that
technology is coming on us
very very fast and it's very convenient
there was an article that i quoted on my
blog
that in new york they found that kids
that were given ipods to listen to
a number of things in english including
songs that they were able to get
out of their special english as a second
language classroom
after one year whereas without that kind
of thing it was
six years and i have always felt this
and that's where
what we put into link get people to
listen to things that they enjoy
get them to put in the time to listen a
lot and they're going to learn
much faster than sitting in a classroom
with 25 other people
who don't speak the language well and
with the teacher who's trying to spoon
feed them
whatever the teacher thinks they should
be spoon-fed
so yes the ipod revolution is coming
and the combination of the ipod and the
internet
essentially makes language labs obsolete
you don't need them if you've got one
too bad
don't build one they're completely
unnecessary
they're they don't provide the range of
content
and the range of functionality that's
being developed for computer
app web apps ipod apps convenient take
it with you
you name it the language lab has is just
a white elephant the only advantage of a
language lab
is that it's something that the school
can show off to a prospective student
in the hope of enticing that student to
come there but if the student is at all
smart he realizes
that he doesn't want to sit in the
language lab if he can be doing most of
those things
on his ipod touch or
other mp3 playing device so i'm going to
stop there because i got a few other
ones
that i want to do thank you for
listening